hello nani hi kamala is that jupiter is  it okay if you move the phone a little  further back i i can't see you oh why  don't you write to me  i wait for the post every day yeah i'll  get on that did you get my gifts huh  yeah look um about the bangle what about  wait which one what the bangle it does  some really  weird things and and that bangle belongs  to my mother aisha the one who  disappeared during partition my great  grandmother faisha  you can't talk to armor look about the  bangle oh but no i've spoken too much  already no no i'm not going to talk  about this at all  come on your mother will get very upset  so this belonged to aisha and you really  have no idea what happened to her oh  peter  [Music]  you